[Música]
bueno pues yo estoy aquí para hablar
realmente de pues de la gran epidemia de
salud del siglo 21 no vengo a hablar del
informe avilés de nuestro reciente
coronavirus sino que vengo a hablaros el
sobrepeso y la obesidad infantil
creo que es importante ponernos en
contexto
para entender la trascendencia del
problema creo que hay una serie de datos
desde 1975 la obesidad se ha triplicado
en todo el mundo pero el rango de edad
entre 5 y 19 años se ha multiplicado por
diez
en el 2016 el 39 por ciento de las
personas adultas tenían sobrepeso si
traducimos estas cifras estamos hablando
de unos 190 millones de personas
y el 13 por ciento eran obesas otros 650
millones de personas pero qué pasa con
los niños en ese mismo año en 2016 41
millones de niños y niñas menores de 5
años menores de 5 años tenían sobrepeso
obesidad
y en el rango de edad entre 5 y 19 eran
340 millones de niños y vidas es decir
si hacemos todo el cómputo del 2016 en
el 2016 había 2 mil 931 millones de
personas en todo el mundo con problemas
de acceso y peso
la oms estiman cada año mueren a causa
de problemas relacionadas con eso de ser
obesidad 28 millones de personas 28
millones de personas son como toda la
población de lituania o como toda la
población del país vasco y cantabria
juntas todos los años
en ese mismo año en el 2016 la revista
harvard medical school publicó un
artículo en el que decía que
probablemente el ser humano haya llegado
a su techo de esperanza de vida
si no conseguimos revertir y atajar el
problema de sobrepeso y la obesidad
infantil es probable que estemos ante la
primera generación de la historia que
viva a menos que sus progenitores
bueno pues no sé pero amigo oyendo todo
esto se me ponen los pelos de punta
sobre todo porque esta gran epidemia no
hace nada más que aumentar
porque no estamos siendo capaces de
atajar este problema si realmente ser
humano es capaz de conseguir cosas
asombrosas
es lo que estamos haciendo bien
bueno pues quizás sea porque la solución
no está en ninguna pastilla no hay
ninguna vacuna sino que la solución está
en generar cambios cambios de vida y
hábitos de vida a nivel individual y a
nivel poblacional
y eso es muchísimo más complicado
pues como habías dicho cristina pues yo
soy pediatra o pediatra rural más
completamente que ya te rural y mi día a
día es pasar consulta de atención
primaria nosotros en las consultas y
vamos observando como este problema de
sobrepeso y obesidad iba cada vez
aumentando más en nuestros pequeños y
pequeños pacientes y que por mucho que
intentábamos trabajar con esas familias
pues los resultados no eran tan buenos
intentamos dispusimos en marcha pusimos
a buscar diferentes enfoques diferentes
manejos en las consultas nos formamos en
distintas estrategias y entonces comenzó
a cambiar mi percepción de el problema
aprendí que había que ampliar nuestro
campo de visión habría que ampliar
nuestro campo de acción y que era era
vital trabajar el problema del sobrepeso
la obesidad infantil desde todos sus
ángulos y desde todos sus problemas
había un pilar fundamental que si no se
tenía en cuenta el resultado no iba a
ser iba a ser buena nueva serviles en
ese pilar es el factor emocional factor
emocional que acompaña todas las
enfermedades pero que concretamente en
el sobrepeso y la obesidad infantil es
un factor crucial
el problema es un problema sumamente
complejo al que lo conseguimos lo
conseguíamos con el frame
y teníamos un montón de factores que
tenemos que solucionar que teníamos que
solucionar había que llegar a miles de
pacientes de una forma efectiva teníamos
que ser capaces de dar una respuesta
desde la pediatría atención primaria
desde desde la base del sistema
sanitario
había que tratar el problema desde toda
la complejidad poniendo énfasis en ese
factor emocional tan importante
habría que conseguir que los pacientes y
sus familias fijas en los contenidos
los fijas en de forma máxima teníamos
que motivar ser capaces de motivar
teníamos que conseguir cambios
intrafamiliares bueno pues había un
montón de problemas a solucionar había
mucho mucho que hacer bueno hay un día
todas estas reflexiones no influyeron en
una forma diferente de abordar el
problema
si lo que hacíamos hasta ahora no
funcionaba porque no hacer algo
totalmente disfruto que consiga generar
cambios necesarios en esas familias para
atajar el sobrepeso y la obesidad y que
facilite el tratamiento de esos
pacientes a los profesionales sanitarios
que estamos al otro lado de la mesa pero
sobre todo porque no vamos a hacer algo
que sea creativo divertido y totalmente
diferente
bueno pues así nació el germen libro
todo el germen de el viaje de mangos es
el el programa de tratamiento integral
del sobrepeso y la obesidad infantil que
estaba se utiliza como herramienta base
de aprendizaje un serious game un
videojuego serio para los niños y niñas
y otro para los tutores un serious game
un videojuego serio está totalmente
integrado con la historia clínica
digital del paciente lo que permite al
profesional sanitario monitorizar
controlar e interactuar directamente con
el paciente permitiendo realizar una
atención más individualizada y mucho más
efectiva
llevamos seis años ha sido seis años de
duro intenso trabajo de estar en una
constante montaña rusa de muchas risas y
de muchas lágrimas también pero ahora el
viaje de mangos es una gran realidad
gracias al fantástico equipo que tengo
detrás cerca de 70 80 personas y es una
realidad espero que pueda empezar a
ayudar a miles de familias y ya en un
futuro cercano los profesionales
sanitarios tanto enfermería como
pediatría de atención primaria de
osakidetza van a poder prescribir el
viaje de mangos esta forma queremos que
nosotros pero escribamos ese programa
los tutores y los pacientes ya van a
poder empezar a jugar en este serios
game y van a poder empezar a adquirir
los conocimientos que se requieren para
el cambio
está todo organizado y diseñado y
realizado para poderlo poner en marcha
de hecho empezamos
pues bueno pues a la primera semana
primera segunda semana de marzo y bueno
eso sí teníamos ya los primeros
pacientes todo listo y lo saben y el cob
y entonces hemos tenido que distribuir
las fuerzas y ahora estamos todos un
poco enfocados en el comité está todo
listo para que podamos empezar el viaje
de mango se va a empezar de forma
paulatina progresiva en todas las dosis
organizaciones de sistemas integrados de
osakidetza
de las tres provincias por unos equipos
que llamamos equipos impulsores es gente
que lleva trabajando conmigo en el
equipo ya tiempo que conoce el viaje de
mangos desde desde hace tiempo están
totalmente familiarizados con connery
que sabe manejarlo perfectamente y serán
y yo también evidentemente los que
pongamos en marcha en el programa con
los primeros pacientes en cuanto a
logística del cómic nos lo permita
esto no es sólo un videojuego es un
programa de tratamiento integral qué
quiere decir esto que es un serios game
en serio tienes la herramienta que van a
utilizar los tutores y los los niños
cada uno tiene la suya van a ir
trabajando en forma paralela y
simultánea y paralelamente más porque
necesitamos que los cambios se generen a
nivel intermedio vale es viaje mangos no
sólo va a ayudar a esos niños con
problemas de peso sino que va a ayudar a
toda la familia
y va a estar articulado con una serie de
consultas presenciales protocolizadas
con sus referentes de pediatría tanto en
enfermería o pediatría en las consultas
se van a hacer consultas pro totalidades
después de cada nivel en el viaje de
humanos en el hijo o sea que eso un mix
de la terapia virtual potenciada o con
la acción de las posiciones sanitarios
es una pregunta que nos hacen siempre
nos hacen varias esto lo van a poder
utilizar los adultos esto lo van a poder
utilizar niños que no tienen exceso de
peso pero pero son
pero son más nutridos con el fatal tiene
unos hábitos no sólo de alimentación
sino de vida porque viaja de mangos va
mucho más allá de la alimentación
entonces en principio no hay
limitaciones en cuanto al uso con este
tipo con los niños por ejemplo normopeso
es mala pues son hábitos correctos
de momento el límite de edad está puesto
en 14 años porque es un programa que
está dirigido a pediatría pero sí que es
cierto que como su programa nuestro
generado por nosotros creado por
nosotros es fácilmente adaptable y
tenemos la potestad de ir viendo las
necesidades que vayan surgiendo y
adaptarlo a las necesidades
[Música]